David oh god Finn wolf sword made me do
it
you know guerilla marketing for my my
one-man show
David Harbor an artistic exploration of
sound light and the soullessness of
celebrity culture hey you should come
see a dress rehearsal
I need honest feedback yeah great just
tell me where I'm nervous
do you know that alley the one next to
the other alley so are you a friend of
David's too
[Music]
I'm now going to tell you about the
first time that I masturbated Jesus
celeb you payment celebeauty pain tits
can you dig it
oh is this me oh wait oh no does it hurt
you is that painful to you so how's the
first day well it's very avant-garde oh
I'm on guard yeah it's unusual but you
like it that's cool just being on a
second higher is you know more stranger
things stuff it's like I've got a
pandering to the fans you know sometimes
a good thing to do
[Applause]
you're a brat prae brat
[Music]
I was a second act what do you think you
want my honest feedback right yeah sure
I am I liked when you play both roles
you got yeah I got that I do think
you're getting some of the dialogue a
little wrong my powers down I also think
some of your recollections about the
strength of things characters is a
little off names Jack Jack demo Gorgon
on the monster from the inside out
you know they don't let me read the full
scripts Josh and then there's the
dancing
[Music]
that's about my new film Hellboy and
about the futility of Fame I didn't get
that from that no because I have a
puppet show about rampant consumerism
and the time that Joe Curie stole my
Golden Globe gift basket I've been here
six hours okay
yeah I know no I'm sorry miss Josh no
we're almost halfway through he doesn't
understand you David you know what I'm
starting to think you might not be the
right manager for me
[Music]
[Laughter]
you